okay so it's my pleasure to introduce
Christian Ika Meyer right
he is now Science Institute but he has a
position at Texas A M works with Joseph
and he will tell us today about given
the complexity field that's right thank
you very much Peter
um okay this is about GCT and tangerine
and Peter already
come gave it talk so about this topic so
this is uh of course all joint work
with Peter
so and
what we want to um
I want to present to you these in more
detail these obstructions that we found
in the tensoring setting that give us a
lower Bound for the Border rank of
matrix multiplication
which is not a which is a non-trivial
bound it's not the word record but it
uses basically all the methods methods
from GCT that can be applied at the
current time
so it's a generalization of something so
I recently found out that this is
actually a generalization of something
that's stress and found so
their theorem I stressing
is um
that they are degree four equations
Vanishing
on bordering
three tensors
okay now we generalize this
db4 equations Vanishing on bordering
three times so um in say
in um
it doesn't matter in some CN tends with
c n tens of c n and N is large
okay so what three stands for is what do
you think
border rank three
pencils those are border rank three
thank you
okay
okay so we generally we would want to
generalize this we want to have things
Vanishing on higher border rank tensors
okay so this is a generalization now
and we generalize this to degree
Copa
oh the degree is a bit higher it's three
couple plus one
equations
this is the equation and it's a vanishes
on
bordering three couple
okay so
um
we'll find all or some some
registered and I just I just take these
and generalize them no don't I don't say
anything about a phone or Auto or
something like that
so the space we are working in
is this um
exactly uh uh on on Border rank less or
you could do yes yes
exactly
okay theoretically are scheme
theoretically you're not saying they're
coming no no no
no some we just find some this is just
anything yeah right yeah this is just
one equation actually so because now
there are no there are more equations
but um
it's not too that though so old it's
just some degree three couple plus one
equations so exactly exactly that
let's just MB large and be large enough
just Envy large enough copper is not um
depends on that
and oh
okay what do we get from that we will
get a um a border rank so um
the result of this would be a lower
bound here of the bordering
sometimes a matrix multiplication
of and then you have to be a bit careful
there's some subtlety here there's a
minus two but um yeah
this will be this would be the lower
ball so when you have this equation you
plug it in evaluate it the matrix
multiplication as you get this
um
low bound but um
we will see how this occurs so in this
and also one feature of this is that
since this method is very combinatorial
and it's not very geometric it also
works for the support rank because
there's no it actually only uses the
support of the tensor
Okay so
let me explain to you how this works and
what's up so there's our space
and we have a group action
that's G at n cross G and cross G and n
and
um
yeah let me call this group
GNN Cube
it's the obvious way right so the first
grnx here the second x0 the Third x here
okay and now there's the unit tensor you
might have heard about
it so I'll write it this way it's E7
yes so it's the sum
I equals 1 up to n
e i tends e i tends e i
and so and we always think of um of
embeddings we emit
so I always do this so just um
so there's no confusion about the
different spaces so this one is embedded
in see two times we'll see two times
with C2
and this one is embedded in C3 and so on
right so you can just if you think of
just Tesla says boxes or numbers
that's very natural and just just have
larger boxes so you just fill up with
zeros if you don't have enough
I just can always embed like this and
now the orbit closure
it's like a group
and Cubed and let it Act
on the end move it around this one
is the set
of
bordering at most n tensors if they I
mean up to some technicality here
set of butter ink
that's equal to n tensors up to up to
some technicality
and the other tensor that we want to
compare this with is the matrix
multiplication tensor
so um the matrix multiplication tensor
is defined as
yeah okay
one to m
and now we have a double index on your
bases just choose any nice way of
indexing it
that's your Matrix notification tensor
and you want to prove now
um
it might be square now right then
squared this one here yes no no this is
I J and K running from 1 to M and this
is double Index this is double index so
those are yes this is double index so
it's CM becomes cm square yes yes yes so
what you get is these these are just
basis vectors in cm squared that's
exactly correct thank you Sean
okay and this is where your where this
tensor lifts and now your n normally
your n would be
would be larger than M squared you know
so just you want to just know
um
how can I somehow and this tensor lifts
somehow in some it of course lives in um
in cm square tens of cm square tensor cm
squared right so it lives certainly here
and you want to have some larger and
yeah let me precisely State the question
so we want to find
n
as large as possible
certification tensor is not in this over
closure
okay that's that was the setting
and now because that's the Border rank
that show is basically a lower bound on
the bordering of the stencil
so
well and and the point is of course
um if we want to do geometric complexity
Theory we do this by actually doing some
function in the vanishing ideal and want
to evaluate this function on this tensor
so that was
um that was the idea so it's let me just
restate this
so it's not in there
if there exists this polynomial f
should be in the vanishing idea
of G and then cubed en
I should have so it should vanish on all
these all these tensors of this water
rank and should have this property
do not vanish
on the matrix multiplication tensor
right this would be nice so on the first
proposition is that we don't have to
consider all the polynomials but we can
um so proposition is we can restrict our
search considerably using representation
Theory and this is also what makes the
whole thing combinatoried in the end
so the proposition is we can restrict
F can be taken right let me say F can be
taken
from an irreducible representation
in this Vanishing area
so the structure on the vanishing idea
and we can use that
so the vanishing idea actually
write it down it decomposes
of anything ideal decompose this into
irreducibles
I'm saying I don't know
and also just give you
images now we just pick
oh we can just always pick
a f that is actually Vector in some
reducer representation this
decomposition is not a unique
decomposition of course
um but the isotopic decomposition is and
um well so
but uh that's not the point at the
moment so just um
it's gln cubed is three copies of glm
so this is the the group that is acting
is genocus Geo and cross gln and it acts
so it acts as follows so if you have a
G1 G2 G3 it acts on say V1 there's a V2
tensor V3 my definition is G1 V1
in cm
oh well if gln then this is in CN so
these yes so those are in CN so this is
yes that's right and Confused yes but I
embed this so I am bad
all these spaces just into the largest
spaces
no no he's that's it I think you just
make it larger it's fine you have the
larger group
so yes
you can embed this and then this all
becomes really fine right and you have
the tensor sitting there okay
so that's the first proposition and so
the proof of this proposition is also
very easy because you can just if you
have an F so proof is just if you have
an F
you decompose it with respect to this
decomposition that you have and then you
just take one of the summons and that's
the summit in the reducible
representation so there's actually
nothing to this if you know that this
that this decomposes then then that's it
basically so basically no the only thing
that you need is that this group is a
reductive group so over your
representation they decompose
well that's nice and um so you're just
saying that AP is the highest Vector is
it yes basically well at the moment not
but but you can restrict yourself so
that's the next step you can restrict
yourself actually to highest rate
vectors yes not everything is the
highest metrical there but you can
restrict yourself because these
irreduciblets are actually
defined basically by the highest rate
vectors then
so what is that a highest rate Vector so
that what ketan said is that you can
actually restrict yourself to highest
rate Vector so what is that a highest
weight vector
so um let me let me
um explain to you what that is
so t
aurus
so it's just the symmetric is diagonal
matrices and take triples of those
um the determinant should be also
non-zero of the Taurus
and U should be the unipotent
this group having once you're on the
diagonal let's start here and also take
Triplets of these so these are your two
groups
and now what is a first of all what is a
weight vector
so a weight vector
I think that if some battery that gets
scaled if you apply an element of these
tutorials here
so I went back to F of weight
and now what is the weight say this is
some Lambda and I want to write so right
notation gets otherwise it gets clumsy
and crowded so I want I want to see
Lambda will be three partitions but I
just want us to see this as this three
partitions this along
it's just some numbers and it's those
are three n numbers okay it's just three
partitions just concatenated so a weight
Vector of weight Lambda
so the Lambda is a triple of partitions
why does it satisfy it satisfies the
following that's basically the
definition
so whenever you have a diagonal matrix
so for all T1 up to t3n
that's your diagonal matrix
and you let this one act on your f
foreign
X on F what should it be it should just
give
G1 should be raised to the Lambda 1
power
until t3n should be raised to the
Lambda 3 n power
so it would be just scheduled so your
your F will be just scaled that's the
weight vector and now um if additionally
we have that
all these group elements in you
oh oh yeah because
yeah yeah but okay that's because I'm
only interested now in in polynomial
representations
okay yes because I will yeah because at
the end it all comes down to polynomial
representations anyway so that's why I
don't care about the others at the
moment uh yeah
you can just always replace the inverse
with the transpose and everything works
always and you always have natural
numbers so everything works
okay so for all group elements in you
um you want to have that
your f is fixed under this operation
under all these operations and this is
now if additionally this holds we call F
A highest rate vector
and the point I want to make is well
this this looks very complicated
but they have a very combinatorial
description and that's this is what I
want to show you now so those are the
really nice commentatorial description
okay so first of all the the most
important thing is why do we care about
highs right vectors is the following
because every irreducible representation
is nothing more than just
um the
span of the orbit of the highest weight
vector
so we can restrict ourselves actually to
highest rate vectors
that's a proposition
every
irreducible
representation
is did in your spin
oh the orbit
off
the unique
highest rejecting there
so this means
we can restrict our search to highest
rate vectors this almost means we can do
that up to up to some group
yes unique up to that's yes thank you up
to square
yes that's true
so we can restrict our search to high
stake pictures
what do I mean by that
I mean that you only so that when you
you only take the highest rate vectors
but it might be that you have to it
apply some group element but that's not
a that's not a serious issue well
basically you're interested in highest
rate vectors so now the point is that
these polynomials have a very
interesting combinatorial structure and
you can basically do everything
combinatory you don't have to think
about all these things anymore it all
works completely combinatory and I want
to show you
uh I don't give you the proofs for this
but I want to show you what kind of
arguments actually you work here
so the dimension
of the um
of the highest rate Vector space
isolate Vector space
operate Lambda
inside
from our coordinating of what we're
actually interested in so let's let's
this is the third tensor power of CN
right this is what we're interested in
at the moment
and say in degree d
ice this is the space of all these
highest rate vectors which is the same
as so the dimension of the size radical
space is the multiplicity
of this irreducible is the same as as
basically you can also Define actually
multiplicity like this
so it's the multiplicity of Lambda
occurring so how often does this
irreducible occur
and this is called
I call it K Lambda and this is the
Konica coefficient
this is the first interesting
observation
that we get um from isometric this year
and now
we can be much more explicit
yeah sure
so when the number of factors is not
constant is
feeding Gately
when when you have more than three
factors you say or what yeah is it still
didn't get it I don't know I I would
have to look at that
the number of tons of factors so when
you have an iterated I think so I would
think that these formula is
I think it's
it's not obvious I mean I think you can
generate I I I would think that you can
generalize the formulas but then we have
okay you think it's okay
but it's not talking
okay this is The Chronic coefficient and
that was a specific question about it
okay let me um
so you can now very precisely say what
is the communal topics here and it comes
from sure wide reality
it says that there's actually this this
Vector space here
a basis a generating set
is given by
now okay of this space let me let me
should have I should have given this a
name
this is the highest rejected space let
me let me give this maybe maybe this is
uh this is now
Lambda
a generating set
of the highest vertical space
is given
by triples of tablets
and this is off-shaped Lambda
so Lambda is a triple of partitions so
this makes sense you have a
if um yeah yeah but Lambda is a triple
of shapes so for example um
so the degree of this whole polynomial
will be
the number of boxes so this is stressens
equation
you could write it with these tableaus
I will show you why this
how you can see with these Tableau
combinatorics that this actually
vanishes on the low end tensors
so this is my stressing
and the chronica here is actually also
one so it's a unique thing
so
okay so it works as follows we want to
um
so I want to interpret this one as a
tensor actually in the tensor space of
the vector space of Tableau so you have
tableaus here table C and tables here
and whenever I write a tableau I want to
I want to think of it as a quotient
space quotient by the grass multiplicar
relations
I don't want to explain the whole
regressment blue correlations now
because I did that in the boot camp but
we only need a single grasp and flicker
relation here so this here grasp and
clicker relations and there's only a
single one that I
want to talk about
and this is the one where when you have
a tableau think of it as a vector you
switch
um two boxes that lie in the same column
then the Tableau switches sign that's
the only thing yes
Vector is just Vector in the sea of like
yeah it's a vector here so it's a vector
here in this space
in
okay it's in this space here
wide reality
diagrams of the road and this uh yes
there's a there's a correspondence it's
called true white reality and I will
tell you how to evaluate such a thing
so what what does this matter is it like
youngster this is a this is a young
tableau
laws
yes yes
so the corresponding partitions are
rectangles oh but those are other
structures equations there are different
sources equations so not the rectangular
ones yes it's not that's not the ones
with the nine boxes this is a different
one
could be that it's just that um
but also are in higher degree degrees
those are in degree nine right because
they have nine boxes so those are the
lower ones but they are not same
invariants okay they're not not
invariant underwear so no it's not so
it's also different each youngster block
responds to factor in uh he of CM
no it's there's a
yes it's a tensor of tablos a tableau is
a in a tableau in a tablespace there is
a the connection is that you go from the
these tensor power of the third tensor
power of CN and you decompose this using
True Value reality and then you have
these
transactions
well this is formerly this would happen
so we have to make all these steps
formally so uh and then you see that you
have a high symmetrical space is one
dimensional so you can basically do
everything over the symmetric group and
it acts here so I just wanted to tell
you the common choice of these vectors
there's a shorter answer which is there
is a map called young symmetrizer which
takes out as input and produces a
polynomial which is in component
mirroring on tensors well that's a nice
answer this is a nice answer thank you
very much you can take those young Super
Choice of course going to those that's
nice and then you also get the same same
thing
okay how does evaluation work because
that's the important thing so the
important thing is why does this thing
vanish on lowering tensors
um
so okay so first thing is I want to
whenever you have a tableau for a table
t
I want to impose the following things so
you when you have when you apply pi to T
then this should be the sign
of Pi
T so it should just not change for pi
I'm using inside the column
that's the easiest crossover correlation
so you would have let this over there
one one three four two it's actually
minus three one four two
and in particular you have the things
vanish now
so for example so the easiest example
that you get so this Tableau is actually
zero because
it's minus itself right
this is why it vanishes
I know um well the magic is that you can
actually evaluate it so you can say
there's a property
when is something like this in the
vanishing idea
of the unit tensor
so this vanishes if and only if the
following vanishes
you take the sum
of all five those are mappings
from the set with d elements to the set
with our elements
and you just apply Phi to the tableaus
yeah that's it basically
and this if this vanishes and this is a
thing in the vanishing idea this is the
only thing that you need and what is
this what is Fifi is a map D so this has
D boxes
the in this case it's D equals four
boxes
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry I
only made f is in the vanishing and you
if and only if this vanishes
why is that true did you say that no I
just stated it
okay
I just stated this okay
um so what happens is um
so this is this is the cover
yes f is your highest weight Vector just
take your highest weight Vector take
this highest rate Vector corresponding
to this Tableau triple then this is the
commercial condition that you need for a
Vanishing um on this on lowering tensors
what is your condition now the condition
is you have these three tableaus you
apply your Phi or is it's a summation of
all maps so all assignments from um from
numbers one up to D so from all these
one up to four numbers two numbers up to
R which in our case would be one up to
three only
R is
um you wanna
oh so it's n you're right so it's n
should be n so it should be three in our
case because we wanted some more or want
this to vanish on rank three tensors
so you plug in numbers here
and where should you replace your
numbers by other numbers
right and then then you see and then you
want to show want to know will the sum
vanish that's the only thing that you
have to do that's just the evaluation of
the uh
of course
exactly that
yeah if you know how the variation
process works now this is exactly of
course the evaluation yes there's
nothing deep in here of course it's just
we have to explain the whole evaluation
process
okay so there's yeah so there's not a
deep ethereum here it's just the
communatorics that are involved when you
construct these with these symmetrics
so now you see why this actually
vanishes because now you apply
um
well if you draw this essay if you do
all these relations with the picture say
this is a one three and four they lie
together in one
so they lie together in the same thing
and there's a two here
so you have one three and four those are
grouped together and you have one two
and four those are grouped together and
you have a one two and three those are
grouped together
so now your task is to assign so fire
assigns to these numbers is
less numbers we only have three numbers
left so you want to assign three numbers
such that this thing here never occurs
because if this occurs then you summon
vanishes right you sum over all those
five but you but you want at least one
summoned that is non-zero right you want
to serve something that is not does not
look like this but the point is it will
always look like this because you only
have three numbers in order that you can
put here and the key property is that
every pair of numbers
lies in some hyper edge of this graph
together which means every pair of
numbers you find somewhere in one of
these columns here so this vanishes
so that's that's well that's basically
the argument
yes it's D equals four n equals three
here
yes decrease four n equals three so now
okay this does not matter at all I mean
you can replace these numbers just by
dots now just for a second to see how
this easily generalizes
so you put a dot here and a DOT here and
a DOT here
and this now the whole argument easily
generalizes you put just more dots you
put another dot here another dot here
another dot here and we added three to
our degree
which basically means just to put
numbers here like five six seven
five six seven should go here
but then this is the five six
construction so you want to have a five
seven so we want to keep this property
right maybe good to mention what you're
doing conceptually as well as
the detail
of course actually I I
raised the degree but the same
combinatorial argument works
so erase the degree but but by the same
combinatorial argument this this
completely works so it's still Vanishing
on rank six this one in this case
that's gone now so this is now
yes I can say that again why this is you
so you place your numbers here
but you only have three numbers you
place your numbers like one one two
three or one one one three or any anyway
doesn't matter this is Phi you you sum
of all those five
but then one of your factors so this
these are factors one of your factors
will vanish because there will be two
numbers that are the same and they will
lie in a hyper rich with each other so
which means they are lie in a column
here with each other which means they
vanish
that's the point so three are not
sufficient here which is basically
um the chromatic number of this
hypergraph is too low so you cannot
really put these things so they
yeah
that's basically the argument the
argument is actually so the chromatic
number chromatic number of this hyper
graph is too low
this is why it vanishes and you can
generalize it by just upping the degree
pretty easily by just putting more
things in here
and this gives you exactly the hook
the hook triple that that gives you this
obstruction
this gives you exactly this Vanishing
property and this is a pretty
combinatorial so this gives us
um this gives us a lower bond that is
actually also it's not only working for
Border rank it's also working for s-rank
for example
yes yes yeah so let me let me yes so
that's also of course important
so but let me just
saying
if you if you you want to show
non-zeroness of course on The Matrix
sensor and this is
it's the same strategy but it doesn't
it's not as easy because
um
it's it doesn't come it's it's uh more
technically involved so let's put it
that way but yeah we managed to do that
so checking
that f is not zero here on the matrix
multiplication tensor
um is not zero is
technical
but involved it's just a long thing to
actually pull this through look where is
the bottleneck because we can't go over
to here sorry oh two by two no whatever
you get lower bound there is some
bottleneck because you said there is
oh yes yes yes yes let me show you that
yes the bottleneck is the following so
we can
um
we can well this is an argument just
that something vanishes but I mean this
is certainly not the only argument that
you can make and if you but if you res
if you only want to use that argument
using only this argument
oh
this argument is converting numbers too
low
but only this argument
then a conjecture by Alan and Kim
it lies
then we cannot get better than uh
that the the leading coefficient can can
not get better than three over two
of the lower bone
cannot exceed three over two
yeah but this is yeah this is if we if
we if we insist on using this kind of
proof there is no another important
thing I mean no no there's no internet
bottleneck so this is actually this is
um if if the slower board exists then
these kind of linear combinations of
this tablets must exist
this is just this yes
when you say this argument do you mean
this argument for showing that chromatic
number is low or do you mean the idea
that the chromatic number is too low
um the chromatic number will just not be
low the correct number you cannot
it's a this is a conjecture about
chromatic numbers and yes
you mean some particular shapes or like
arbitrary shapes I mean arbitrary shapes
triple products
not linear combinations
this is only yes this idea uses not
linear combinations
this is exactly only these and and
chromatic numbers so it's very limited
but still works all linear combinations
of tablets you can use linear
combinations of tableaus which is so in
general it's not clear that a single
triple of tables gives you anything
which normally you would have to have
linear combinations but in our case so
okay let me let me State one more thing
so this one here that the Chronicles one
this is true for all our cases so also
for the larger ones so it stays one and
this means
basically this is um is An Occurrence
obstruction in the sense of of the GCT
program because there is only a single
highest rate Vector up to scale and that
one vanishes which means all of the
highest weight vectors vanish because
there is only one so this is An
Occurrence obstruction well this is
basically the reason why it is in our
current obstruction because this stays
one of it yes I can yes so
this is only because this is one
chronica coefficient of Lambda so this
is the multiplicity of Lambda in the
ambient space and if you prove that the
highest effective lies in the vanishing
idea then the whole isotopic component
of course lies in the vanishing idea and
this is why it's An Occurrence
obstruction this is the deeper reason
why it is like that
it's no other reason for that
okay I think I think
right thank you very much
on the
that particular tensor but he wanted to
prove that from the G orbit also it was
yes yes it vanishes not only on the
itunishes No No it's it's like this is I
approved this one here F vanishes on on
the F lies in the whole Vanishing idea
yeah okay
yes yes yes it's not like the sensor
only okay that's true that's true
exactly yeah yeah no thanks
yes so I mean I mean this argument using
only this argument and by this I mean
I mean this argument the chromatic
number is too low that's a very specific
way of proving that these things vanish
you should mention that you've already
gone beyond just simply using oh so yes
yes yes are you we are not restricted to
this we sorry yes so with jmsberg and
John howernshine we proved with using
these methods we proved that the Border
rank of two times two matches with
multiplication is seven and we don't use
these methods very
um it gets so tablets get very
complicated and so we use computer
support to do that but that's um so we
find actually
um what the partition triple that gives
um that proves that the Border rank of
two times two matching certification is
seven reproving a result by JM from 2004
which I think even in your thesis you
use UMD on chromatic
today the thesis I'm pretty sure it's
this one is why chromatic numbers
so in this approach you are just using
this um sorry it's a Craftsman relations
right for flocal relations
no the other one's not no no it's just
this one is very I mean this one is very
limited but still works so this one is
very very limited this is the easiest
one to analyze right this is and it's
it's completely open how to I mean there
is a lot of leeway you can go in all
directions here it's very I mean this is
only very using very limited techniques
at this point
the other ones I mean yeah it becomes
complicated combinatorics becomes just
more involved right so but in in
principle yes that's possible yes
so you need to understand straightening
yes but switching is complicated yes but
it's exactly the point yeah
straightening is is the key Point here
and we and this is nice because you
don't need to use certainly so it works
without
no more questions
it's interesting that without
straightening you could get anything
yes it's not amazing
well we do a little bit well it's just
tiny straightening here right it's just
in the columns the complicated thing
it's only the easy ones
thank you
anyways